well something I haven't been enjoying
seen lately is Justin Bieber and his
behavior I do love his music but he has
been melting down he's been berating
fans walking offstage so what's going on
with the Biebs well Justin's finally
shedding some light on what's got him so
upset if you're screaming and super
overwhelming it's hard for me to kind of
connect with you
oh so it's Beliebers you are getting too
feisty that's what my tossing Justin
says is wrong with some of his most
vocal fans you know the ones he's been
scolding
screaming the two heroes as the fans get
older and they start understanding how
to act and they actually want to act a
little bit more sane so that maybe they
get my attention so act more mature and
you'll get nice justin got it in a new
documentary on high-profile bodyguards
Biebs confesses it's not just the
screaming that concerns him I felt like
my safety was at risk it may sound crazy
but three four little girls and they
have so much strength
Bieber's director of security for the
last three years explains it's been
tough protecting the 22 year old from
his own overzealous fans they were
nearly rip his shirt take off his hoodie
and you can lose them in the crowd
ahead of yesterday's concert in Croatia
Justin arrived at the airport flanked by
guards having security
it's a creates space for me it creates
boundaries
that's all Justin needs he just has to
have a little space between him and his
fans you know it's got to be tough to be
that public right well we'll see how he
does tomorrow night he's playing for a
sold-out crowd in pole